[Applause]
it's kind of blurry it's better question
what kind of bear is best it's a
ridiculous question
false black bear well that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets so bears
beets Battlestar Galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses $4 and it only cost me $7
to recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of lemon dollars
here's going to happen I am going to
have to fix you manage you two on a more
personal scale a a more micro form of
Management Jim what is that called micro
German boom yes now Jim is going to be
the client Dwight you're going to have
to sell to him without being aggressive
hostile or difficult let's go all right
fine ring ring hello hello this is
Dwight Schrute from the Dunder Mifflin
paper company well that's great because
I need paper excellent then you are in
luck because we are having a limited
time offer only on everything wow this
is my lucky day what is your name sir I
am Bill buttlicker really that's your
real name
how dare you my family built this
country by the way you're respectful 20
please yes Michael you know what
imitation is the most sincere form of
flattery so I thank you any theft is not
a joke Jim millions of families suffer
every year Michael oh that's funny
Michael one second that's my other one
what no but I blue yeah no I'm just on
the phone with this stupid salesman he's
so dumb probably just gonna keep him on
the line forever and not buy any
okay it's up to you to change mine sorry
that was a family emergency
Oh No what's wrong you know what that's
private boundaries white hey hey who are
you
faxing so early in the morning oh I know
explain I don't have a ton of contact
with his grandma branch but before I
left I took a box of Dwight's stationery
so from time to time I send Dwight faxes
from himself from the future Dwight at 8
a.m. today someone poisons the coffee do
not drink the coffee more instructions
will follow cordially future Dwight
don't thank me later as I was saying so
we are having a limit of a little bit
louder I'm hard of hearing
sorry he's an old man okay as I was
saying right now we're at louder okay
our prices have never been lower when
you have to talk loud never been lower
louder son but maker our prices have
never been lower hey that's totally
inappropriate
you should never yell no just listen to
me sir here we go the three words I
would describe you as is aggressiveness
hostile and definitely difficult please
mister by my rate right you know the
phones give me a chance give me the
phone mr. buttlicker me the phone I have
to put on with my boss well I should
hope so who is this hello this is
Michael Scott regional manager well this
is William M buttlicker
hello mr. buttlicker how may we help you
Michael I like the sound of your voice
you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna buy one
million dollars over the paper products
today yeah it's done thank you very much
sir I don't think you'll regret it you
are the master there is one condition
Michael yes you have to fire the
salesman that treated me so terribly
don't do it Michael
it's a million dollar sale where is my
desk that is weird this is not funny
this is totally unprofessional okay well
you're the one who lost the desk I
didn't lose my desk okay calm down
where was the last place you saw okay
who moved my desk I think you should
retrace your steps okay I am going to
tell Michael and this entire office will
be punished colder warmer a little
warmer Hey ooh
warmer warmer warmer warmer warmer cold
cold cold back up warmer hot red hot
very hot Dwight Schrute
hi um what sort of discounts are we
giving on the 20 G I'm giving you this
information like 20 times
let's buy the ream do things now 978
sorry it's a disc a seven-person okay
thank you gotta get back to work okay so
do I in your own words someone replaced
all my pens and pencils with crayons
I suspect Jim Halpert everyone has
called me Duane all day I think Jim
Halpert paid them too yes five bucks
each and it was totally worth it you
look cute today boy thanks girl
so yesterday Dwight found half a joint
in the parking lot which is unfortunate
because as it turns out Dwight finding
drugs is more dangerous than most people
using drugs I'm just saying that you
can't be sure that it wasn't you that's
ridiculous of course it wasn't me
marijuana is a memory loss drug so maybe
I just don't remember I would remember
well how could you of it just erased
your memory that's not how it works no
how do you know how it works
knock it off okay I'm interviewing yo
you said that I'd be conducting the
interview when I walked in here now
exactly how much pot did you smoke this
morning I found a bloody glove in my
desk drawer and Jim Halpert tried to
convince me I committed murder I think
he may be the real murderer Jim Halpert
said there was an abandoned infant in
the woman's room when I went to save the
child
I saw Meredith on the can yeah smile no
I never smile if I can help it
showing ones teeth is a submission
signal in primates when someone smiles
at me all I see is a chimpanzee begging
for its life
this came out really well there you go
this is humongous I am NOT a security
threat and my middle name is Kurt not
fart what did I write this morning I
knocked myself in the head with the
phone that actually took a while I had
to put more and more nickels into his
handset until he got used to the weight
and then I just took him all out every
time I typed my name it said diapers
just a simple macro morning Dwight who
are you Who am I
I'm Jim we've been working together for
12 years we're joke Dwight you're not
Jim Jim's not Asian you seriously never
noticed
hey hats off to you for not seeing race
alright then Jim uh why don't you tell
me about that sale that you made
yesterday
Wellington systems sold them ten cases
of 24-pound lighter stock or were you
talking about Krieger Murphy because I
didn't close that one yet but I'm hoping
I've got a voicemail from Paul Krieger
waiting for me please enter your
password
you have one new message
no no no no that is sensitive
information only for employees not
Outsiders white cut it out I'm trying to
work you don't work here you're not Jim
Jim I got us that dinner reservation
Rico 7:30 oh great can't wait Jim's at
the dentist this morning and Steve is an
actor friend of ours I don't know who
you are but you are not Jim this is Jim
you